[Musique]
il ya deux usages principaux des
techniques biométrique de reconnaissance
faciale le premier usage chez
l'authentification l'authentification
s'est vérifié qu'une personne est bien
ce qu'elle prétend être c'est une
application qu'on a par exemple déjà
dans certains aéroports la deuxième
grande famille d'applications c'est
l'identification et là on cherche à
savoir qui est cette personne et ça
suppose que on est outre le gabarit
biométriques de la personne une base de
données un fichier dans laquelle on va
les chercher ici on connaît la personne
concernée sont des outils qui évolue à
toute allure les algorithmes sont de
plus en plus fiables mais la france avec
son règlement sur la protection des
données personnelles et je dirais est
très limité donc nous ce qu'on propose
c'est une loi d'expérimentation qui nous
permet dans certains cas bien précis
d'utiliser cette technologie tout en
protégeant les libertés publiques en
mettant clairement des lignes rouges des
interdits par exemple pour éviter toute
discrimination raciale ou sexuelle et
donc pour protéger nos libertés il faut
protéger notre souveraineté et donc
donner les moyens à nos entreprises de
développer les technologies nous
proposons une base de données européenne
nous souhaiterions aussi parce qu'il
faut des contrôles un organisme européen
qui serait en charge de
reconnaître la fiabilité des algorithmes
développés de contrôler et puis il ya
évidemment un énorme sujet qui est celui
de l'hébergement des données et là aussi
nous pensons nous proposons qu'il y ait
un effort européen et un contrôle
européen nous interdisons la notation
sociale la reconnaissance des émotions
l'utilisation par les acteurs privés
tout ce qui est utile isation en temps
réel sur la voie publique sans contrôle
donc on a un cadre qui est extrêmement
sévère pour que la reconnaissance
sociale ne devienne pas une intrusion
dans nos vies personnelles pour nous
c'est non seulement le parlement doit
s'emparer du sujet mais c'est le moment
de le faire avant que la législation
européenne intervienne et comme les
français sont très quartiers d'été zia
pendant que d'autres pays anglo saxons
sont beaucoup plus empirique ils sont
l'expérience nous nous pourrions
conjuguer les deux être un pouvoir
d'influencé important
[Musique]